* Angestrengtes Keuchen *
Hey!
* Sie pfeift. *
Das kannst du mir geben.
- Wie soll ich dir das geben?
Irgendwie ist mir ein wenig ...
Nein, mach das doch nicht!
- Ich komme nur so ...
* Entspannte Reggae-Version:
"Uf u dervo" von Gölä *
Eine Ferienlodge
mitten in der Pampa von Uruguay.
Ruedi Althaus
treibt vor Ort das Projekt voran,
führt Verhandlungen
und kauft eine Baumaschine,
während Susanne in der Schweiz
weiterhin Geld
für ihren Auswanderertraum verdient.
Salut!
Vorerst in der Schweiz bleiben
auch die Kinder der Familie Kunz.
Die Eltern übernehmen an der Nordsee
einen Imbisswagen
mit Würsten und Pommes frites.
Also führen Sie z.B. Pommes?
Auch frische Pommes?
Ein Motel
und mehr Zeit für die Familie:
Dieser Traum soll sich für
die Almeidas in Kanada verwirklichen.
Huch! Jesses Gott!
One moment ...
Sie kämpfen
mit den Tücken des Alltags
und empfangen die ersten Gäste.
# Uf u dervo.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Vogelzwitschern,
sanfte Saitenklänge *
Der Tag beginnt früh
für Beatrice und Josef Almeida.
Was war in der Nacht noch los?
Es reicht für einen kurzen Kaffee,
dann geht es ab ins Motel.
Es ist Sommersaison.
Jemand muss das Frühstück für die
Gäste zubereiten: Speck und Eier.
Momentan sind wir das,
mal schauen, wie das in Zukunft ist.
Im Moment
stehen wir jeden Tag früh auf.
Ich mache das gerne.
Ich arbeite eigentlich gerne.
Ich will nicht alles
von anderen machen lassen.
Natürlich wäre es schön,
an einem Wochenende ausschlafen
zu können, aber so ist es nun.
Früh aufstehen müssen auch die Kinder
Sophie, André und Robin,
obwohl die langen Sommerferien
begonnen haben.
Sie begleiten ihre Eltern zum Motel.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Drei Eier reichen aus. Ja?
Ein exquisites Frühstück für
die Gäste mit viel Selbstgemachtem.
Das liegt den Almeidas am Herzen.
Mutter Beatrice ist gelernte Köchin.
Und die Kinder helfen mit.
Gut. Danke schön.
* Er spricht englisch. *
Er ist ein guter Gastgeber.
Er beherrscht viele Sprachen, ist
immer freundlich zu allen und ...
Im Gegensatz zu mir.
Ich brauche morgens etwas Zeit.
Seit der Eröffnung vor drei Monaten
arbeitet das Ehepaar Almeida
sieben Tage die Woche.
Dabei wollten die beiden
hier in Kanada
eigentlich mehr Zeit mit der Familie
verbringen - und nun das.
Auch wenn man
ausreichend geschlafen hat -
man ist den ganzen Tag dran
und auf Achse.
Man backt Zöpfe,
macht dies und jenes.
Ja.
Das geht auf Dauer nicht.
Man kann nicht
sieben Tage die Woche arbeiten.
Man kann sagen,
dass es nur saisonal ist, aber ...
... es ist trotzdem streng.
Wir brauchen mal eine Pause.
Aber so schnell
gönnen sich die Almeidas keine Pause.
Just careful! Okay, gut.
Jetzt einfach nirgends streifen,
Sofie!
Drück fest zusammen! Bravo.
So.
(Sofie) Was machst du damit?
- Raus.
Und immer kommt noch etwas dazu:
Trotz Hochsaison wollen sie
die Gästezimmer renovieren.
Und das hier ... Schläft Robin?
Na, dann gute Nacht!
Notschlafstelle.
* Beatrice lacht. *
Das Zimmer
wollen sie streichen lassen.
Robin, bitte!
Du hast ganz schmutzige Galoschen.
- Nein!
Du bist ganz schmutzig.
Steh bitte auf!
Weshalb?
- Weil ich es dir sage.
Au!
- Au, au!
Altes muss neuem Platz machen:
100 Möbelstücke
zum selber Zusammenbauen
haben sie sich liefern lassen.
Oh, der ist schwer.
Sofie, willst du den?
* Josef kichert. *
Siehst du, was für einer das ist?
- Die 1 von ...
Alle 18 Zimmer
sollen neue Möbel bekommen.
Wir haben das in diesem Jahr gekauft
und viel Geld investiert.
Wir hatten nicht vor,
noch einmal so viel Geld
in jedes Zimmer zu investieren.
Man muss wirklich etwas machen,
das ist echt ...
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Jahrelang war die stürmische Nordsee
die liebste Feriendestination
der Familie Kunz.
Jetzt werden sie hier
zu Unternehmern.
Gut 4'000 Euro investierten sie
in die Beschriftung ihres Geschäftes,
den Küstenimbiss.
Ich glaube, da braucht es
schon etwas ... Geschicklichkeit.
Das ist schon verrückt.
* Pfeifender Wind *
Das braucht noch etwas Übung, was?
Bis die Karre offen ist.
* Brigitte lacht. *
Hast du das Kleine abgeschlossen?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich weiss es nicht mehr.
Hier habe ich nicht abgeschlossen.
Der ist offen oder zu -
keine Ahnung.
Der Wagen bleibt verschlossen.
- Der geht nicht mehr auf.
Du musst in die andere Richtung
drehen. Genau.
Ja! 100 Punkte.
- Warum auch immer.
Pommes-Peter, der Vorbesitzer, führte
sie bereits in die Grillküche ein.
Und die Betriebsbewilligung
haben sie problemlos erhalten.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonmusik *
Wir mussten einen Kurs besuchen.
Wie lange dauerte der?
Ich glaube 2 Std. oder so.
Es war nichts Weltbewegendes.
Es ging ums Thema Hygiene.
Ich glaube, das ist das Wichtigste
im Gastgewerbe.
Genau. Es war ... nichts Spezielles.
Einfach, wie man Dinge lagert ...
... Händewaschen usw. Ja.
Mehr brauchen wir nicht,
da wir keinen Alkohol ausschenken.
* Pfeifender Wind *
Schau, die Sonne kommt hervor.
Die Sonne kommt.
Das ist halt Nordsee-Wetter.
Damit muss man leben.
* Brigitte lacht. *
Das ist halt so.
Hier oben an der Nordsee
bläst der Wind halt ziemlich oft.
Es nimmt Form an, was?
- Ja, das wird gut.
Die Haltbarkeit dieser Folie
beträgt ca. zehn bis zwölf Jahre.
Wir hoffen, wir halten es auch
so lange hier an der Nordsee aus.
Ich meine ... das ist jetzt
sozusagen unser kleines Baby.
Das ist so. Wir starten am Freitag.
Wir hoffen,
dass viele Leute kommen werden.
* Entspannte Reggae-Musik *
Noch ist Ruedi Althaus
alleine in Uruguay.
Seit Wochen arbeitet der 53-Jährige
tagtäglich auf seinem Grundstück.
Die wichtigste Baumaschine
ist dabei sein Radlader.
* Exotische Perkussion *
Fünf lange Wochen
hatte er auf die Lieferung
von Baggerschaufel und -arm gewartet.
Man kann damit keine
kilometerlangen Löcher ausheben.
Aber für kleinere Gräben oder Löcher
reicht es.
Bei diesem Boden ist man froh, wenn
man es nicht von Hand machen muss.
In knapp zwei Jahren soll hier
ein kleines Ferienparadies entstehen.
Dann wird Ruedi, der Bauschreiner,
zum Gastgeber.
Wir sind 15 Autominuten
von Colonia entfernt.
Von Colonia aus gibt es eine
Schnellfähre nach Buenos Aires.
Von dort erhoffen wir uns Gäste.
Argentinien erlebt momentan
zwar nicht gerade goldene Zeiten.
Aber auch das wird sich erholen.
Wir sind der Meinung und hoffen,
dass es funktionieren wird.
Wenn es nicht so sein sollte,
ist es dann noch früh genug,
schlaflose Nächte zu haben.
Wenn das jetzt schon der Fall ist,
muss man gar nicht erst beginnen.
* Exotische Musik *
Noch im Emmental ist seine Susanne.
Sie ist in die Einliegerwohnung
ihres Hauses gezogen,
das sie mittlerweile vermietet haben.
Täglich
bekommt sie Nachrichten aus Uruguay.
* Exotische Musik *
Ich denke schon:
"Es ist unseres, es ist meines."
Ich fühle mich zu Hause,
wenn ich die Fotos anschaue.
Und dieser gelbe Wohncontainer wird
bald schon ihr neues Zuhause sein.
(Spanisch)
Cómo estás?
- Lindo, gracias. Tu?
Schon lange bereitet sich Susanne
auf die Auswanderung vor
und besucht seit zwei Jahren
einen Spanischkurs.
Traiga la ...
... e cuenta.
Das brauche ich vielleicht,
wenn ich mal einen Hund habe.
Nur noch wenige Wochen,
dann kann sie in Uruguay zeigen,
was sie gelernt hat.
* Entspannte Reggae-Musik *
Die Auswandererkinder Robin und André
sind in Tatamagouche
gut aufgenommen worden.
Innert kurzer Zeit
haben sie Freunde gefunden.
In den dreimonatigen Sommerferien
haben sie Zeit,
sich noch besser kennenzulernen.
Meistens kommen sie hierher, weil
das Motel ein guter Treffpunkt ist.
Man sagt:
"Wir treffen uns im Motel."
So gut wie jeder in der Stadt weiss,
wo das Motel ist.
Das Engagement und die
Gastfreundschaft der neuen Besitzer
zahlen sich aus.
Das Motel ist ausgelastet.
Neben den Reinigungshilfen
haben die Almeidas
seit Kurzem auch eine Rezeptionistin
stundenweise angestellt.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden mit Wilma.
Sie ist eigentlich eine Studierte.
Sie spricht drei Sprachen.
Aber in erster Linie
entlastet sie uns.
So haben wir auch ein Familienleben,
können auch mal früh nach Hause
und sind nicht immer
bis 21 Uhr hier im Motel.
Das ist
die wöchentliche Lohnzahlung.
Immer mittwochs
wollen sie ihr Geld ...
... in Form eines Checks.
Von der Büroarbeit bis zu
den kleinen Ärgernissen des Alltags:
Die meiste Arbeit
nehmen Almeidas selbst in die Hand.
Der Griff einer WC-Spülung
ist kaputt.
Im Keller stehen noch alte Toiletten,
ein kleines Ersatzteillager.
Bin ich jetzt blöd? In welche
Richtung muss ich schrauben?
Das muss man doch irgendwie lösen.
- Ja, irgendwie.
Ich versuche es noch einmal.
Ich glaube, es geht wirklich
in die andere Richtung.
Ich glaube,
den habe ich schon kaputtgemacht.
* Beatrice lacht. *
Meinst du?
Es sieht ganz danach aus.
Das ist ein Scheiss ... ein Murks.
* Hämmern *
* Rauschen *
* Gurgelndes Rauschen *
* Beatrice
spricht leise vor sich hin. *
Geschafft.
Der neue alte Griff ist montiert.
Ich glaube, das ist gut.
Er ist der Schlepper,
wenn es darum geht, etwas zu tragen.
Er hat sehr viel Kraft.
Und ich sage, wo lang... und wohin.
Eigentlich bin ich eher diejenige,
die ...
... wie soll ich sagen ...
... die ein besseres Verständnis hat
oder versteht,
wie etwas funktioniert.
Aber ich brauche ihn dann,
um die Schraube zu lösen
oder was auch immer.
Wir ergänzen uns da ganz gut.
Wenn man so ein Motel hat,
muss man gewisse Dinge
selbst erledigen können.
Wenn man für jede Kleinigkeit
jemanden braucht,
kommt man erstens nirgends hin
und zweitens kostet es zu viel.
Das ist gar nicht möglich.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Puh, ist das kalt!
Ah, qué frío!
Es ist August und Winter,
als Susanne in Uruguay ankommt.
Die Sonne scheint!
Die Sonne scheint und es ist kalt.
Ruedi war kurzerhand in die Schweiz
geflogen, um sie abzuholen.
Deine Katze.
- Ja, meine Katze, die hat kalt.
Mit dabei: Katze Ghöri.
So schnell wie möglich fahren
die Emmentaler zu ihrem Grundstück.
Wirklich jedes Mal,
wenn ich hierher komme,
finde ich es extrem schön.
Diese Weite und das Unendliche.
Jedes Mal ist es anders.
Man ist dem Himmel etwas näher.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Ja, Kleiner, gleich sind wir da.
Ich freue mich darauf.
Nervös bin ich nicht.
Wenn etwas nicht gut ist,
müssen wir umbauen.
Da drüben siehst du es.
Schau her!
Der Gärtner mäht gerade.
* Ticken des Blinkers *
Das ist überraschend.
Der ist ja unglaublich.
Was die 52-Jährige
von Hunderten von Fotos kennt,
ist plötzlich Wirklichkeit.
Moment.
Oh.
Und dann noch eine Überraschung:
Ihre Freunde Marc und Elisabeth,
zwei ausgewanderte Zürcher, sind da.
Salut.
- Hallo.
Geht's dir gut?
- Ja. Und selbst?
Hallo.
- Hallo Susanne.
Herzlich willkommen.
Bist du so müde? So traurig?
Nein,
ich bin überhaupt nicht traurig.
Bloss etwas überwältigt von all dem.
Hey, hast du gesehen,
was dein Mann geschafft hat?
Nein, du hast noch gar nicht ...
Komm!
Ja, es ist gut.
Möchtest du dein neues Zuhause
anschauen? - Ja, gerne.
Nachher müssen wir
unsere Katze herauslassen.
Das ist es also,
ihr provisorisches Zuhause:
der gelbe Wohncontainer.
Ah, cool! Aber kalt.
Kalt?
- Kalt.
Dann wärmen wir etwas.
Ah, hier.
* Es piepst zweimal. *
22.
- Schön, schön.
Super.
Wir müssen hier
halt etwas zusammenrücken, was?
Jetzt auf der Hinfahrt ...
... wurde mir erst richtig bewusst,
dass das
unser zukünftiges Zuhause ist.
Ich wusste ja,
dass wir hierher kommen,
aber jetzt ist es real.
Aber es ist gut, wirklich gut.
Möchtest du herauskommen, Kleiner?
Na?
Schau, das ist dein neues Zuhause.
Ja.
Und jetzt?
Auch Ghöri
erwartet eine Überraschung:
Katze Tigerli.
Sie lebt schon lange
auf dem Grundstück.
Jö!
Sie springen einander nicht an
die Gurgel. Das ist doch ein Anfang.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Schön, schön.
Du musst dich halt
an diese Sonnenuntergänge gewöhnen -
die sind meistens so. - Ich weiss.
Du hast sie mir geschickt.
Vielen Dank.
- Vielen Dank.
Es ist unglaublich schön.
Vielen Dank.
- Ich bin froh, dass ihr hier seid.
Gesundheit.
* Schmatzer *
(Sacha Kunz)
Guten Morgen. Wie geht's?
Gut und dir?
- Alles okay?
Ja.
- Ist es heiss, Timo?
Nicht so.
- Aber 30 °C sind es, oder?
27.
Ah, okay.
- Perfekt.
Etwas wärmer als hier.
Es dauert nicht mehr lange,
bis ihr hier seid.
Nein. Heute gehen wir ans Meer.
Das ist gut.
- Geht ihr im Meer baden?
Noch sind die Kinder der Familie Kunz
auf Kreta in den Ferien.
In einer Woche
werden auch sie nach Dorum kommen.
Ja.
- Na?
Also, ist das gut?
(Beide) Geniesst es!
- Ja.
Wir haben noch viel zu tun.
Tschüss!
Tschüss zusammen.
- Geniesst die letzten Tage!
- Tschüss.
Ich habe euch sehr lieb. Tschüss.
Brigitte und Sacha haben kaum Zeit,
die Kinder zu vermissen.
Denn schon
steht das Grillgut vor der Tür.
Wahrscheinlich
ist das nicht alles für uns.
Denke ich. Aber genug.
Wir haben natürlich viel bestellt.
Das ist die erste Lieferung.
Ich glaube,
es braucht entsprechend Ware.
Da morgen die Eröffnung ist
und dann das Wochenende kommt,
dachten wir, wir machen
den ersten Einkauf richtig.
Richtig heisst:
200 kg Pommes frites -
und zwar frische,
keine tiefgefrorenen,
und das von einem Lieferanten,
der alles frei Haus liefert.
Die Garage ist ihr Kühlhaus.
Gefrorene sind qualitativ
sicher länger haltbar.
Aber wir brauchen
relativ viele Pommes frites.
Ich denke, dass wir
die brauchen werden - noch mehr.
Nimm einen neuen.
- Hier oben.
Achte auf die Lüftung!
Für die Wahl der perfekten Grillwurst
luden sie deutsche Freunde
zum Probeessen ein.
Da wir in der Schweiz
andere Würste und Bratwürste haben,
dachten wir, dass es sinnvoll wäre,
die Deutschen probieren zu lassen.
Nicht nur wir selbst. Ich glaube,
das war durchaus sinnvoll.
Das sind Currywürste,
die sind 180 g.
Die werden wir
sicher am häufigsten brauchen.
Das sind Currywürste.
- Die kommen zuoberst.
Das sind die Richtigen, oder?
- Ja.
Kurzerhand
haben sie 1'000 Würste geordert.
Ja, wir können es
nicht ganz genau sagen.
Aber effektiv
hat uns der Vorgänger gesagt,
dass wir
ungefähr so viel einkaufen sollten.
Denn es ist viel los,
es ist Ferienzeit.
Es ist halt sehr wetterabhängig:
Ist es warm und schön,
ist die Platte voll.
Regnet es, ist sie leer.
Es ist so ...
Wir können es nicht wirklich sagen.
Gut, hier ist das Geld.
- Viel Erfolg.
Danke schön.
- Dass Sie immer was zu tun haben.
Das machen wir doch. Super.
Schönen Tag.
- Danke dir, tschüss.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Für einmal sind die Almeidas
nicht bei der Arbeit.
Im Balmoral Motel
hat Rezeptionistin Wilma Dienst.
Mami, Papi,
darf ich dort herumfahren?
Hier hast du mehr Platz. Komm!
- Lieber hier. Nur hier.
Oh, schau, da hat es Wespen.
Die gemeinsame Freizeit
zu Hause geniessen -
das schaffen die Almeidas nie lange.
Auch hier gibt es immer etwas zu tun.
* Angestrengtes Keuchen *
Hey!
* Sie pfeift. *
Das kannst du mir geben.
- Wie soll ich dir das geben?
Keine Ahnung.
- Rückst du etwas rüber?
Irgendwie ist mir ein wenig ...
Nein, mach das doch nicht!
- Ich komme nur so ...
Jetzt kann ich es dir reichen.
- So, ja, tipptopp.
Ist das gut?
- Ja.
Das Dach ist undicht.
Wenn es regnet, tropft es manchmal
beim Kamin etwas rein.
Deshalb versiegeln wir es jetzt.
Das ist einfach so.
Da kann man nichts tun.
Wenn der Wind quer weht,
tropft es unten in die Küche hinein.
Aber das hört dann wieder auf.
Es ist, wie's ist.
Wir machen das hier schnell.
Ist es jetzt besser?
- Tipptopp.
Gut.
Kann ich wieder hinuntergehen?
Brauchst du mich noch hier oben?
Nein, es ist okay.
- Vorsichtig, ja?
Vorsichtig, vorsichtig.
- Für heute sind wir hier fertig.
Ich glaube, das Schlimmste
ist das Hinunterschauen.
Ich brauche eine andere Hose.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Heute fährt die ganze Familie
ans Meer.
An der Blue Sea Beach wollen Almeidas
ein paar Stunden abschalten.
Doch allen gelingt das nicht.
(Englisch)
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Bye.
Hast du abgeschlossen?
Ja.
Gut.
Wonderful. Thank you.
Wir sind immer präsent im Motel.
Deshalb versuchen wir, immer wieder
an den Strand zu kommen,
wenn das Wetter schön ist.
Auch mal für 1-2 Std.
Vielleicht nicht 1 Std.,
aber 2-3 Std.
Keine ganzen Tage,
dafür etwas öfter,
denn alle lieben das Wasser.
Es ist herrlich, herrlich.
Ganz still.
Es sieht fast aus wie am See.
Und es ist einfach da.
Das ist ...
* Sanfte Musik, Möwenschreie *
* Gemächliche Musik *
* Möwenschrei *
* Beschwingte Akkordeonmusik *
Gut überlegt, ist halb geklebt.
Nur: Stimmt, was da steht?
Eigentlich wäre es wirklich links.
- Jetzt ist es aber so.
"Bitte rechts anstellen" heisst,
dass das hier drüben ist.
Und das ist irgendwie ...
Nein, man bestellt hier
und steht dann rechts an,
um die Dinge entgegenzunehmen.
Ich bin nicht deiner Meinung.
- Du hast recht, ich weiss.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal
nicht deiner Meinung.
Ich muss wirklich sagen ...
- Du musst das Gute daran sehen.
Meiner Meinung nach ist das falsch.
Eigentlich wäre es wirklich links.
Gut, also.
- Du kannst es nicht mehr ändern.
Heute ist das Nebensache.
Wichtiger sind die Preise.
Ihr Grillwagen muss künftig
die ganze Familie ernähren.
Dann haben wir Curry-Bratwurst.
Drei.
Dann haben wir Krakauer.
Ähm ... 3.10 Euro.
Wir gingen
von unsere Einkaufspreisen aus ...
... und haben sie multipliziert ...
... mit einer speziellen Formel.
Diese habe ich im Internet gefunden
und dann noch
mit dem Steuerberater angeschaut.
Hallo.
- (Frau) Hallo ihr Süssen.
Alles gut?
- Alles gut.
Die Preise der Schweizer
interessieren auch Margret.
Sie ist Besitzerin des Trinkbrunnen,
dem Wagen nebenan.
Kaffee: 1.90.
- Macht ihr auch 1.90?
Ich habe das auch.
- Ja. Wir passen uns an.
Die anderen nehmen alle weniger.
- Ah, noch weniger? Okay.
Die nehmen 1.50.
Kaffee ist nicht mein Hauptgebiet.
- Ist bei mir auch so.
Das ist doch egal, oder?
- Ja, die Getränke ...
* Gemächliche Akkordeonklänge *
Für Margret
ist Familie Kunz keine Konkurrenz.
Einem erfolgreichen Eröffnungstag
steht also nichts mehr im Weg.
Hältst du ihn?
- Ja, ja.
Gut?
Diese Seite.
Voilà.
Auffüllen können wir morgen.
Ja, es dauert noch knappe 15 Std.
Von daher ...
Wir freuen uns jetzt,
legen uns sicher noch etwas hin
und bereiten uns etwas vor,
aber ich glaube,
in dieser Nacht
werden wir nicht viel schlafen,
weil wir doch ein Kribbeln
verspüren, das soll auch so sein.
Ja. Alles ist bereit.
Mayonnaise, Currysauce.
Sonnenschein, aber nur 8 °C.
Die erste Nacht im Container
ist vorüber.
* Exotische Musik *
Die Katze hat die Nähe gesucht.
Er war die ganze Nacht bei uns.
Er hat sich schön dazwischen gelegt.
Die Küche ist zu klein.
- Wieso?
Für all das, was wir mitgenommen
haben und was du erhalten hast.
Na ja ...
- Nein, es ist super.
Bis der erste Bungalow steht,
wohnen die beiden auf knapp 14 m2.
So, jetzt gibt es hier
schon viel mehr Platz.
Ja, ja.
Als ich heute aufgestanden bin,
wollte ich schon alles umstellen.
Ich habe die Junggesellenwohnung
meines Mannes auf den Kopf gestellt.
Ja.
Ich fand, das Katzenfutter
kann man ins Badezimmer stellen.
Das muss ja nicht in der Küche sein.
Es hat ja Platz im Badezimmer.
Das kann man machen. Solange du
das Bier im Kühlschrank lässt ...
Ja, das lasse ich schon
im Kühlschrank.
Möchtest du einen Kaffee?
- Ja, gerne.
Drinnen oder draussen?
- Ja ... Wir können rausgehen.
Wir können den Hocker reinnehmen,
wenn es zu kühl ist.
Nein, gehen wir raus.
Wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen.
Wow, so schön!
Die Messer?
- Die habe ich. Das Brotmesser.
Gut.
Lecker. Guten Appetit!
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Unser erstes Frühstück. Super.
Super.
Die Wohnung ist umgestellt.
Jetzt herrscht Ordnung.
Das ist gut, das ist schön.
Sehr schön.
Eigentlich ist es schön:
Wenn es neben einem im Bett
friedlich schnarcht,
weiss man,
dass man nicht mehr alleine ist.
* Lockere Reggae-Musik *
Nachher würde ich mir gerne
das Grundstück anschauen,
wie sich alles entwickelt hat.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Die Gemeinschaft der Almeidas
wird immer grösser.
Oft sitzen Angestellte und Freunde
der Kinder gemeinsam am Mittagstisch.
Ich finde das gut. Mich stört auch
nicht, dass wir an der Strasse sind.
In der Schweiz
hat mich das immer gestört,
hier finde ich es total okay.
Man hat einfach
andere Ansprüche ans Leben.
Ich kann es nicht in Worte fassen.
Es ist einfach locker und megacool.
Zehn Messer und Gabeln, Schätzchen.
Noch haben die Almeidas
eine Art Probezeitstatus in Kanada.
Are you looking for me?
- No, no.
Ihre Aufenthaltsbewilligung
ist vorläufig noch befristet
und an einen Vertrag geknüpft.
Schwarz auf Weiss zwischen mir
und der Majestät the Queen.
Ein Vertrag.
Nur unterschrieben hat sie nicht.
Erfüllen sie den Vertrag,
können sie in zwei Jahren
das Aufenthaltsrecht beantragen.
Wir mussten die
bestehenden Angestellten übernehmen
plus neues Personal einstellen -
wir haben drei Leute eingestellt.
Eigentlich haben wir alles
schon mehr oder weniger erfüllt.
Und sie wollen bleiben.
Die ganze Familie sputet sich,
um das erste renovierte Zimmer
fertig einzurichten.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es heute Abend aussieht.
Aber morgen ist dieses Zimmer
schon wieder besetzt.
Wir müssen schauen,
dass wir fertig werden.
Das ist kein Schmutz,
sondern ein Kratzer.
Nicht schlecht. Es sieht schön aus.
Es gefällt mir gut.
Das sind Meilen
im Vergleich zum alten Geschwür.
Wichtig ist,
dass es den Leuten gefällt.
Ich biete einfach den Raum an,
in dem ich selbst
auch gerne übernachten würde.
Jetzt fühle ich mich hier besser,
hier würde ich schlafen.
* Bohrgeräusche *
* Gemächliche Musik *
Huch! Das hält, ja?
- Halte dich rechts am Dach fest.
Dann geht es einfacher.
Für einen Blick über ihren Besitz
steigen Susanne und Ruedi
auf den höchsten Punkt ihres Landes.
Das ist ja sensationell!
Unglaublich.
Hier braucht es unbedingt
eine Terrasse. - Ja.
Die unendliche Weite,
direkt vor ihrem Container.
* Lockere, entspannte Musik *
Gewaltig.
- Ja.
Ja, das ist schön.
Das bereitet Freude.
Es ist ein Privileg,
so etwas machen und haben zu dürfen.
Ich bin schon froh, wenn es hier
mal eine richtige Treppe gibt.
Ja, ja.
Geht's?
- Ja.
Ich muss wohl
eine grössere Leiter kaufen.
(Spanisch)
100 Betriebsstunden: Der erste
Service am Radlader ist fällig.
Nach vier Monaten im Land
kann Ruedi sich schon verständigen.
Das Gute ist,
dass die Menschen hier ziemlich ...
Sie helfen einem und versuchen
selbst, wenn man etwas ...
Bis jetzt hat es immer geklappt.
Aber Konversationsspanisch
beherrsche ich noch nicht -
und werde ich wohl
auch nicht so schnell.
Du möchtest zum Brunnen gehen?
- Ja.
Damit wir
von unten her schauen können.
* Entspannte exotische Musik *
Das ist mein Reich.
Hier wird die Küche sein,
das Restaurant und ...
... die Rezeption.
Wenn ich hier stehe, denke ich,
dass es etwas klein ist, nicht?
Das ist immer so.
- Ich weiss.
Das war ja bei uns zu Hause auch so.
- Genau. Es wirkt immer kleiner.
Ihr Haus in der Schweiz
hatten sie selber gebaut.
Deshalb wagt Ruedi,
auf den Baumeister zu verzichten.
Als ich angekommen bin,
habe ich mich mit dem Baumeister
zusammengesetzt und das besprochen.
Den habe ich dann nicht genommen.
Schlussendlich hatte ich die
Bauherrschaft. - Die Bauleitung.
Zu Beginn, beim Betonieren etc.,
war noch die Architektin involviert.
Das war so abgemacht.
Wir haben dann geschaut,
was ich selbst machen kann
und was ich
nicht selbst machen kann oder will.
Wenn man alleine betoniert,
kommt man nirgends hin.
Das wäre purer Schwachsinn.
Den ersten Bungalow ihrer Posada
werden die beiden selber beziehen.
Unser zukünftiges.
Hier werden wir am Anfang sein.
- Ich stehe gerade im Bad.
Nein. Doch.
- Du stehst in der Küche.
Hier ist der Eingang.
Ins Bad geht's hier drüben.
Ach, ja!
Hier ist die Küche,
hier das Badezimmer.
Hier gibt es ein Zimmer ...
... und dort drüben
gibt es ein Zimmer.
Hier vorne ist das Wohnzimmer.
Und hier vorne eine Terrasse
nach draussen.
Wohnen mit Aussicht.
- Genau.
Wenn der Erdhügel weg ist.
Sie hoffen, schon bald einzuziehen.
Zuversichtlich gesagt in drei
Monaten, aber das ist sportlich.
Aber ...
- Jetzt sind wir zu zweit.
Zu zweit geht vieles einfacher.
Das Wetter an der Nordsee
ist eine launische Sache.
So, hinein in die Stube.
Doch Regen ist am Eröffnungstag
nicht angekündigt. So oder so:
Brigittes und Sachas gute Laune
kann heute kein Wetter verderben.
400 Würste hat er im Kühlschrank.
Es ist eine schöne Arbeit.
Eine andere Arbeit, das ist so.
Aber ich glaube,
es macht dann auch Spass.
Wir hoffen,
dass auch Leute kommen werden.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Ich glaube, dass die Leute
neugierig sind und vorbeischauen.
Hoffentlich konsumieren sie auch.
Ich denke,
wenn wir etwa 100 verkaufen,
haben wir ein gutes Fazit
des heutigen Tages.
Es gibt noch ein paar verschiedene
Anlässe in dieser Region.
Vielleicht verläuft sich ja
der eine oder andere noch.
Ein Vogelschiss.
Das wird aber noch geputzt.
Es hat noch mehr.
Vogelschiss bringe Glück, aber nur,
wenn man ihn selber abbekomme -
behauptete jedenfalls
der Vorbesitzer.
* Beschwingte Akkordeonmusik *
* Sacha lacht. *
Ich glaube, es reicht, Schatz.
Da musst du nichts mehr machen.
Warum? Willst du mir sagen, dass du
schon alle Stühle geputzt hast?
Ja. Nein, die Stühle nicht.
Doch, alles.
Wenn ich mich
irgendwo hinsetzen möchte,
hätte ich auch gerne
einen sauberen Stuhl -
zumindest einigermassen.
Du musst nur oberflächlich putzen.
Alles ist sauber.
Nein, also wirklich!
- Wir haben keine Zeit mehr.
Wir müssen gehen. Ich muss braten.
- Du hast einfach keine Lust.
Schau dir das Wasser an!
- Ja, ja, schon klar.
Die Zeit läuft.
Noch eine knappe halbe Stunde -
nicht einmal.
So, jetzt schalte ich den Grill an.
Das Ehepaar Kunz hat es gewagt:
Die einstigen Angestellten
sind Unternehmer geworden.
Wir haben schon Schnuppertage
absolviert, das hat gut geklappt.
Das ist ein wenig in den Genen,
und ich mache es gerne.
Und, ja, ich denke,
wir werden uns in der ersten oder
zweiten Jahreshälfte einarbeiten.
Schatz, können wir öffnen?
Ja, einen Moment.
- Das habe ich schon geputzt.
Sacha wird langsam nervös.
Schatz!
Nein, ehrlich.
Du kannst ja auch alles wegnehmen.
- Was wegnehmen?
Du kannst alles abreiben.
Ich habe doch schon geputzt.
Nein, nicht richtig.
Du hast nur drüber gewischt.
Ist gut?
- Gut, du kannst langsam kommen.
Langsam!
Gut.
Ja, das ist gut.
So.
- Was?
Geöffnet.
* Brutzeln *
So. Ich bin bereit.
- Bist du bereit?
Die Leute können kommen.
- So.
Aber wir haben ja noch ...
... knapp 17 Min. bis zur Eröffnung.
Und dann ...
... ja,
beginnt ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Kassensturz am Eröffnungstag -
und das Ehepaar Kunz
hat ein erstes Problem:
Wir haben eine leichte Verstopfung
in der Fritteuse.
Hoi!
- Hallo!
Dann kommen ihre Kinder
in Deutschland an.
Alles gut?
- Ja.
In Kanada gibt es eine grosse
Veränderung im Leben der Almeidas.
Abschied ist nie etwas Schönes.
Ich finde es immer etwas schwierig.
Mutter Beatrice
fährt für zehn Wochen in die Schweiz.
Und: Abenteuerliches Leben
auf der Baustelle in Uruguay.
Auf uns!
Susanne packt mit an.
Irgendwie bin ich
noch völlig überfordert mit allem.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt,
# chöme nümme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
ufder Suechi fürnes nöis Dehei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2020